>> Bret: AND TWO NIGHTS
"WHATEVER HAPPENED TO" SEGMENT,
OVER SURVEILLANCE ON AMERICANS.
THE INFORMATION HAS ALSO HAD
MASSIVE IMPLICATIONS IN EUROPE.
CORRESPONDENT GILLIAN TURNER HAS
OUR STORY TONIGHT FROM
GREAT BRITAIN.
>> AT ONE TIME AND AS A
CONTRACTOR AND CIA EMPLOYEE
EDWARD SNOWDEN IS BELIEVED TO BE
IN HONG KONG TONIGHT HIDING OUT
AFTER LEAKING INFORMATION.
>> IT SHOOK THE WORLD DURING THE
SUMMER OF 2013 AND EVER SINCE,
THE NATIONAL SECURITY AGENCY AND
CONGRESS HAVE BEEN EMBROILED IN
AN EPIC BATTLE OF MASS
SURVEILLANCE.
HE PUBLICLY CONFESSED TO
STEALING A TROVE OF HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED INTELLIGENCE ABOUT
U.S. SURVEILLANCE PROGRAMS.
SNOWDEN HANDED THAT INFORMATION
OVER WHOLESALE AND IN THE
PROCESS, REVEALED THAT THE INTEL
COMMUNITY WAS COLLECTING
INFORMATION ABOUT AMERICANS
SUSPECTED OF HAVING TIES TO
TERRORISM.
THAT PROMPTED A NATIONAL OUTCRY.
>> WHAT SNOWDEN DID MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE AS HE BROUGHT ONE
WORD TO THE FOREFRONT, PRIVACY.
HE BURST PEOPLE'S BUBBLES.
>> A LOT HAS HAPPENED IN THE
ENSUING YEARS SINCE VERY PUBLIC
FALLOUT.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS INSIST THEY
ABUSE THEIR OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY
TO TAMP DOWN ON NSA OPERATIONS.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
REFORMS, MOST OF WHICH I CAN'T
GO INTO BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHAT HAPPENED WITH SNOWDEN
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> I WOULD FOLLOW THE LAW, AND I
WOULD INSURE IF CONFIRMED THAT
THE AGENCY FOLLOWS THE LAW.
>> CONGRESS AND THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT ALSO ESTABLISHED THE
U.S. CYBER COMMAND TO PROVIDE
MILITARY SUPPORT FOR U.S.
NETWORKS AND WHILE INTEL EXPERTS
WIDELY VIEW THESE STEPS AS
EFFECTIVE, THEY ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE NSA CONTINUES DATA
COLLECTION OF AMERICANS.
ABOUT 530 MILLION CALLS IN JUST
A FEW EUROS.
>> THE PROBLEM IS WE ARE
COLLECTING MORE AND MORE BUT THE
REAL QUESTION IS, HOW MUCH OF
THIS ARE WE REALLY PROCESSING?
HOW MUCH CAN WE MAKE DECISIONS
ON?
>> EUROPEAN COUNTRIES WERE ALSO
HIT HARD BY THE SNOWDEN
REVELATION.
BRITAIN'S GOVERNMENT IN
PARTICULAR IS STILL GRAPPLING TO
THE STATE WITH MAJOR FALLOUT AS
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT RESTRICTED
ACCESS TO AMERICA'S DATA,
BRITAIN'S PARLIAMENT WENT IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
IT PASSED LEGISLATION KNOWN AS
THE SNOOPERS CHARTER IN 2016
THAT REQUIRES INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO KEEP BROWSING DATA
FOR A YEAR DOWN LIKE A YEAR.
IT'S BEEN FOUGHT OVER IN THE
HIGH COURT VIRTUALLY SINCE THE
DAY HAD PASSED AND JUST LAST
MONTH THE COURT RULED IT